wir sind noch nicht zurückgefahren
sondern wir sind hier in einer
Metrostation jetzt das sind die Menschen
die hier sind die Schutz gesucht haben
als die Raketen auf den tv-turm geflogen
sind ich nehme euch aber mit hier lang
so sieht der Shelter aus wir sehen hier
kleine Kinder die Schutz gesucht haben
bewegende Bilder
die haben die Explosion gehört sagt er
und sind dann hierher geflüchtet how
long are you play in the shelter
er weiß es noch nicht aber wir sehen er
hat hier Zuflucht gesucht mit seinen
beiden kleinen Kindern in der Metro
Patricia bewegende bedrückende Bilder
wir sehen hier viele Menschen die in
dieser Metro vor dem Krieg geflohen sind
wir haben gerade die Bilder gesehen auch
hier Mädchen die Flucht suchen in Decken
verhüllt
wir haben die Bilder gesehen was Krieg
bedeutet und das sind die Folgen des
Krieges Menschen die sich hier in einer
Metro Station verstecken vor weiteren
Bomben Patricia und Karl Paul in den
ersten Tagen oder in den ersten Stunden
dieses Krieges auch in der Hauptstadt
Kiew da war das ja so da hat man diese
U-Bahn-Schächte aufgesucht wenn der
Alarm kam aber mittlerweile gewinnen
auch hier wieder Eindruck so scheint er
zu sein man richtet sich im Grunde auf
ein leben dort in dem Schacht an
ja das ist auch mein Gefühl also wir
sehen hier viele Lebensmittel Menschen
haben hier ihre
Habseligkeiten teilweise mitgenommen in
Tüten
wir sehen hier teilweise ganze Familien
die dort sind
und die und und die und die sozusagen
hier jetzt im Platz gefunden haben hier
einen Hund der da ist
das beruhigend ist sicherlich in so
einer Situation ein Haustier zu haben
ja da sehen wir die alte Reklame
als hier in Kiew noch alles normal war
die Reklame in den Metro Schächten und
das sind die Menschen alle die geflohen
sind als die Raketen gekommen sind dann
gab es auch natürlich hier wieder die
Sirenen die wir immer wieder gehört
haben aber
so sieht der Krieg aus zeigt hier noch
mal einmal
zwei völlig erschöpfte Frauen die
traurig
und nicht wissen wo sie hin sollen Kai
und Patricia
dort in einer U-Bahn man sieht im
Hintergrund bei dir Paul hinten wie das
gesagt hast noch die Reklame die Werbung
und kann sich also vorstellen wie noch
vor wenigen Tagen dort die Menschen
entlang geeilt sind um zur Arbeit zu
kommen und jetzt sieht man die Menschen
dort mit Decken auf dem Boden ja bereits
in der Not dort weiter für Tage für
eventuell Wochen auch auszuharren und
fassbar wieder dort von Paul ronsheimer
das berichten ja die Menschen die dort
sind was kannst du dort beobachten ich
habe gesehen es sind viele auch kleine
Kinder Babys dort unter den Menschen die
vermutlich auch nicht mehr sich trauen
überhaupt nach oben zu gehen und nach
Hause zurückzukehren
ja das ist so Patricia viele wissen auch
nicht wie lange sie hier bleiben müssen
wir haben ja gehört dass um den tv-turm
herum vier Menschen mindestens ums Leben
gekommen sind und in dem Fall keine
Soldaten sondern Zivilisten und wir
haben ja die Zerstörung gerade eben
gesehen von daher
Menschen die das erlebt haben in ihrer
nächsten Nähe die gesehen haben was
Raketen anrichten können wir haben
natürlich noch viel mehr Panik in ihre
Häuser überhaupt zurückzukehren was ja
auch eine völlig verständliche
Entscheidung ist von daher gehe ich aus
dass mehr und mehr Leute die hier
bleiben die nicht fliehen noch wäre es
ja theoretisch möglich dann am Ende auch
versuchen ja rauszugehen und
versuchen in einem Bunker zu bleiben ich
versuche mal englisch
so tell me white
from the rocket attack here
ja sie sagt dass sie draußen waren als
das ganze passiert ist ja Experiment
[Musik]
eine Mitteilung bekommen das ist ein
attack eine Attacke geben würde how to
get the notification mobile
also es gab eine Warnung hier wir handy
app und wir verschiedene
Regierungsseiten und da gab es die
Warnung dass es hier eine Attacke geben
könnte
Rockets with fire that the TV Tower
sie war hier in diesem Bunker und man
hat diese Explosion beim TV Tower auch
hier gehört und gemerkt und die
windelwände haben gewackelt so etwas
shaking ja also ist halt ein wenig
nicht gewackelt ja
ja
what what happened
sie waren gerade von zu Hause
zurückgekommen hier zur U-Bahn
also sie hat die Rakete selbst gesehen
und im gleichen Moment ist alles
explodiert so your song the rocket
workoutside when the rock it WiFi and
[Applaus]
sie hat die Rakete fliegen gesehen und
hat dann gesehen wie das Ganze
explodiert ist how come you not Insel in
your beautiful dog how are you what's
your dogs name
also auch ihre Schwester hat es
geschafft ich gehe einmal auf die Seite
hat es geschafft rauszukommen obwohl sie
große Angst natürlich hatte Patricia
also das ist die Situation what you dogs
neben mir Kari Kari den Hund haben sie
auch mit rausbekommen
und so ist die Situation hier sieht so
you have enough to drink for how many
days
[Musik]
ah okay das okay
Sie also man hat sich vorbereitet hier
haben wir nicht days are you gonna stay
with your dog and everybody hear in the
shelter
okay sie wissen noch nicht wie lange sie
hier in diesem Platz bleiben werden
Patricia und Kai das ist die Situation
hier in dem Bunker der Metro Metro die
genutzt wird als Bunker weil es ebenso
tief ist die haben den paketeneinschlag
direkt miterlebt und halten sich jetzt
hier auf auch aus Sorge dass noch mehr
passieren kann der Paul wir saugen diese
Momente mit dir auf die du uns
mitbringst aus dem Krieg aus der
Hauptstadt den Kiew wo du diese Stunden
mit den Menschen dort in der Metro in
der U-Bahn gerade verbringst die dort
Schutz suchen was mich irritiert und
gleichzeitig finde ich es bewundernswert
ja es strahlt die Menschen strahlen fast
eine gewisse Gelassenheit in diesem
Moment eine aus es herrschte unheimliche
Ruhe dort ja offenbar in den
U-Bahnschacht das heißt beschreib uns
diese Atmosphäre und worauf stellen sich
all die Menschen dort ein ist ja eine
lange Geschichte ich leite die Frage
vielleicht einfach weiter kein das
können die Menschen besser beschreiben
tut mir
warum seid ihr so optimistisch obwohl
hier der Krieg herrscht
sie hofft dass ihre Verwandten am Leben
sind die sind weiter weg von Kiew ähm
was ist
keine optimistic in some ways ist der
something
ja sie sagt Weinen und Schreien hilft
nicht sie haben bereits geschrieben sie
haben geweint auch das hat nicht
geholfen diesen Krieg zu beenden bei
deinem Schuhe dog always help you got
right what the name
also du siehst hier der Hund beruhigt
die Menschen hier in der U-Bahn in der
Türkei und sie sagen es bringt halt
nichts die ganze Zeit zu weinen und die
ganze Zeit traurig zu sein denn das
haben sie alles schon versucht und es
hat nichts verändert am Krieg in der
Ukraine das verstehe ich Paul das ist
jetzt schon die Zeit nach den Tränen bei
dir dort in der U-Bahn kannst du die
jungen Frauen noch einmal fragen was sie
jetzt alles bei sich haben ob sie planen
nach Hause noch mal zurückzukehren wie
sie jetzt diesen Tag dort unten
verbringen was sie überhaupt noch ja
dort unten haben damit sie auch diese
Stunden diese Stunden in Angst in
irgendeiner Form auch schneller vergehen
ja zur people in Germany wanna know like
how are you prepared to stay here and
what do you have you and you have to go
home
gebracht weil es ja kalt ist in der
Nacht das sind hier Decken und draußen
schneit es ja wie wir wissen
how do you drink
also manche Menschen haben ihr Essen
aufgebracht die haben ein bisschen
mitgebracht wird Harmony days can you
stay here without going wie lange kannst
du hier bleiben ohne
sie ist schon seit sieben Tagen hier und
es können noch weitere Tage werden
Patricia
was machen die Frauen die bei dir sitzen
in ihrem Leben abseits des Krieges was
haben sie noch vor einer Woche gemacht
how do you see the future of you country
ist er the chance to resist against
Puten ist eine Chance gegen Putin hier
der Sieg ist auf unserer Seite sagt sie
weil der kriegt dauert schon 7 Tage also
Kai haben wir die raketeneinschläge
gesehen hier unten sehen wir die
Menschen und sie sagen sie sind immer
noch optimistisch sie sagen 7 Tage Krieg
und Wladimir Putin hat Kiew noch nicht
erobert und Paul Bernd uns du uns all
diese Bilder diese Menschen zu uns
bringst nach Deutschland sehen wir die
Welt der Diplomatie und das wirkt in
diesen Minuten fast absurd gleichzeitig
im Bild nämlich aus Jerusalem ein
Livebild dort wird gleich der
Bundeskanzler sprechen auf Israel Besuch
natürlich geht's da auch im Kern um den
Ukraine Krieg und dann kommt gerade die
aktuelle Meldung rein die läuft gerade
hier über den Agentur TK Paul das
angeblich neue Gespräche vorbereitet
werden das Russland zu neuen Gesprächen
bereit sein mit der Ukraine und während
das kommt ich habe gelesen während du
dort unten sitzt bei den Menschen das
wirkt völlig entrückt das wirkt absurd
in diesem Minuten in denen wir die
Gesichter des Krieges bei dir sehen
und ich kann sagen keiner hat hier
Vertrauen da rein das irgendwie Wladimir
Putin ist ernst meinen könnte mit
Gesprächen das soll der Hund ist so
schön den muss ich ab und zu streicheln
das ist
mit mit Gesprächen hier ähm dass man
glaubt nicht dass Vladimir Putin ist
wirklich ernst meint denn das haben wir
auch beim letzten Gespräch gesehen er
will dass das Existenzrecht das hat
hatte Ukraine das Existenzrecht genommen
von daher ist die Frage wie soll man da
eine Verhandlungsbasis führen
vielleicht zählt Paul kannst du auch
noch mal die jungen Frauen dort in der
U-Bahn Station ansprechen was ist ihr
Wunsch ihre Forderung auch an
Deutschland
nicht
solution
glauben Sie wirklich dass sie hier
diesen
bin kein Militärstrategie ist Taxi
sie hofft dass sie damit aufhören werden
stoppen werden mit dem Krieg weil sie
dann am Ende vielleicht auch der Druck
größer werden könnte von den Menschen
danke Paul für den Moment dort in der
U-Bahn von Kiew wo die Menschen Schutz
suchen in vor den Bomben vor den Raketen
Putin